happy Sunday evening this is Q&A Sunday
and I've got some great questions from
last Sunday evening so I just wanted to
scroll through and answer some of these
questions we've got one from Stuart
Brice which says Samuel how do you go
about finding the average rent in an
area really really good question Stuart
when you're buying a property you need
to know what the rent is and I always
say everything will rent out at the
right price you just need to figure out
what the right price is how do you do
that well there's a few ways one way is
to just go on Rightmove and Zoopla and
see what's renting in the area currently
so see what the competition is if you're
expecting to get 700 per annum of rent
but there's a house similar that's on
the market for 600 pounds and it's not
rented in three months then you know
that you are know we're going to get 700
pound so what most renting - what's
rented so look on sites like open rents
and you can see what properties
previously rented and what rented is
more important than what's renting
because if it's on the market for over
700 but it's not rented then it might be
overpriced so you need to see what's
renting what's rented and then the last
thing is talk to local agents talk to
letting agents in the area asked them
you know say look I'm looking to rent
this property Apple but I guess
sometimes I even pretend to be a tenant
and ring up and pose to be a tenant and
ask questions about the area the price
is what I can get from the money and
that's all part of your due diligence
when buying a house so hope that helps
your brightest - bryce thank you so much
let's see what else we got we've got a
danny GI who says how the hell will you
be able to manage properties from all
around the world
great question listen I don't manage my
own properties so if I did it would be
physically impossible because I've got a
lot of houses and I do travel the world
so how do i how do i how do I do it what
I actually have is I have property
managers for each house so if I've got
HMO in Liverpool I'm gonna have a HMO
management company that manages that
property they've got a single that in
Wales I've got a by Gillette management
company that'll manage that and I
usually pay a roundabout
10% of the rent to management companies
however because I've got so many
properties sometimes managing property
managers can almost be as bad as
managing tenants so I have property
managers but then I have an overseer and
the overseer is someone who's a member
of my staff full-time and the overseer
manages the property managers who manage
the tenants and the overseer is the only
person who's allowed to speak to me
direct and we just touch base once a
month five minutes I'll say hey what's
going on how's everything going with the
properties and that's my system so you
definitely can have properties managed
for you otherwise it's not passive
income it's just it's just a job if
you've got people that's why when people
say you know I only want to buy close to
home so I can keep an eye on the
property I'm like that's a really bad
plan a because what that means is that
means that that there will be problems
and you will step in and that's not
financial freedom that's a rope around
your neck that's not an investment
property that's a headache so really
important to get good management
companies set up and that is how I
manage my properties from all around the
world so HUD the helps let's see what
else we got david keene e5 says how do I
say to my parents that I don't want to
go to college but want to get into
flipping houses to start with and gaming
capital and then using that capital to
gain a portfolio of renting properties
all right how do you tell your parents
David my advice on this is just just
tell them like in the way that you just
told me
just tell them I mean so many people are
just so afraid of what their parents are
gonna say or think or their ex
schoolteachers or their husbands wives
siblings life short you know on every
tombstone there's two dates and then
there's a - in the middle and right now
we're in that little - right now and
life life is really short so I just
think you've just got to live life to
the fullest and if you feel like you
want to be a property investor and you
really want to do this you don't want to
go to college what's the point of going
to college to get a job
if you don't want a job what it's
ridiculous what would you spend years
studying and training and investing in
something in the hope that that will
give you that when you don't want that
like just to please somebody I think we
need to stop trying to please people I
really do I think that people are so
bothered about what their parents think
and try not trying to yearn for approval
just do you man just do you because
ultimately your parents will respect you
more and your parents trying like trying
to stop their kids it's out of fear and
love they love you and they're scared
because they think oh no because they
believe that it's not possible it's too
hard but it really is because I did it I
started at 17 years old and I was
financially for you by 21 started with
no money at all so you can do it man you
just kind of just stand up go for it
that ultimately be proud of you but
you're gonna do you Kevin Liu and I hope
I'm pronouncing this right I Sam you
love the videos I've read both of walk
by Loretta hi financially three to seven
days and just finished Alistair's book
I've gone to a few property networking
events and have booked onto your crash
course like June what advice would you
give me in the meantime
as I want to get involved more without
being a motivated idiot thanks again and
keep doing what you're doing what do you
mean you want to be involved more
without looking like a motivated idiot
the thing is you can be involved without
investing into property just yet so the
only way you'll be a motivated yet is if
you rush into something and spend a lot
of money investing in a property or a
deal or or a joint venture partnership
without the right training that's what I
call a motivated yet but if you're going
to property networking events and you'll
read in and you're studying and you're
mixing with the right people you go to a
property auction make friends see how it
goes go and view properties meet with
agents tell them what you're trying to
do but just what I would say is that's
not and being a motivate an idiot that's
it that's called being a sponge that's
called immersing yourself in property so
all these things some of the stuff that
you're already doing is exactly what I
would do you're on the you
come to the crash course in June that
the slight late June that that's real
soon we're just talking which is talking
about a couple few weeks away so Mike my
thoughts would just be I think sometimes
where people just need to get patient
sometimes people say you know I'm books
on the course but oh my gosh I just
can't wait I need it you know just just
breathe you know
you get started you can start going to
property networking events and you can
read books and you can view houses and
you can speak to agents and you can ring
an accountant and ring a mortgage broker
and tell them this is what I'm trying to
do how can you help me you can start
thinking positively so that when you get
trained you're in the right headspace to
be able to then take action all this
stuff is it's fantastic and I would and
I would do you can maybe go get some
business cards printed with your name on
it and that way when you come to the
training programs and you start thinking
oh my gosh I can do this I can find
properties I want to sell these houses
now I want to join venture wanna then
you've got business cards and you can
pass them to people who you make friends
you've on the program so you could
potentially be joint venture partners
all the source stuff this is not being a
motivated here this is just called being
a sponge you've got to be a sponge man
you've got to be a sponge but yeah
you're right though about I mean a
motivated here is someone who invests
their murmee on property without being
educated because that's just nuts
because as I always say property is the
best investment after yourself because
you are ultimately the best investment
you'll ever make in that's been helpful
if you are booked onto the crash course
I sincerely look forward to seeing you
if you're not then come down come and
meet me spend a couple of days together
and really put together your plan to
financial freedom have a lovely lovely
evening and I look forward to seeing you
tomorrow on mentoring Monday at 7 p.m.
peace out guys little love
you